Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
collègues nous recevons aujourd'hui le
docteur bohic et Messieurs Froissart
ritier membre de l'inspection des
affaires sociales et auteurs du rapport
qui va nous occuper dans leur avenir
non je viens de dire la même chose à nos
collègues les collaborateurs n'assistent
pas c'est une direct qui avait été
définie je suis désolé
voilà merci
donc nous recevons aujourd'hui donc le
docteur bohic et Messieurs froissartier
membre d'inspection général des affaires
sociales et auteurs du rapport qui nous
occupent l'IGAS a été saisi en juillet
dernier par le ministre des Solidarités
de l'autonomie et des personnes
handicapées Jean-Christophe combe à la
suite de plusieurs signalements et du
décès d'une fillette dans une crèche
afin de mener une mission d'évaluation
des processus et des mesures mises en
oeuvre afin de garantir la sécurité la
bientraitance des enfants accueilli en
crèche vous avez mené une enquête et
avait remis votre rapport intitulé
qualité et prévention de la maltraitance
dans les crèches le 11 avril dernier
nous avons été nombreux à nous émouvoir
des conclusions de ce rapport j'y
reviendrai mais il me semblait opportun
que notre délégation puisse vous
entendre et je vous remercie de votre
présence aujourd'hui
à ce stade de mon introduction je tenais
à saluer l'engagement des professionnels
de la petite enfance qui font ou tente
de faire au mieux leur travail pour
assurer le développement de ses enfants
dans leur premier mois de la vie et je
pense qu'il faut leur apporter notre
soutien
il me faut également préciser que les
crèches sont très majeurrement très
majoritairement pardon opéré soit par
des opérateurs privés soit par des
auteurs territoriaux l'état intervenant
comme financeur parfois formateur plus
rarement comme ordonnateur je pense ici
au crèche à VIP porté par la CAF
j'ai particulièrement noté la réaction
de l'AMF reprenant votre préconisation
d'amélioration de la formation c'est
évidemment une solution à mettre en
oeuvre en coordination avec les régions
mais du coup prendra un peu de temps y
a-t-il des solutions rapides que vous
pourriez préconiser sur ce sujet il nous
faut également entendre que la présence
de crèche est très souvent un argument
de campagne électorale je pense que nous
avons collectivement une responsabilité
car ces promesses engagent et il importe
de les mettre en oeuvre car c'est un
gage de dynamique d'un territoire mais
dans le temps il faut aussi les
entretenir et les pérenniser dès lors
confier la mise en oeuvre opérationnelle
des crèches à des opérateurs devient
tentantes cela évite un accroissement de
personnel et permet une souplesse accrue
dans la gestion avec les écueils que
l'on connaît que l'on constate
vous établissez dans votre rapport un
constat critique sur cet accueil et
mettez l'accent sur les besoins de
l'enfant je vous cite la logique
quantitative d'accroissement de l'offre
à devancé les objectifs qualitatifs pour
une réponse adaptée aux besoins de
l'enfant dès lors il nous faut nous
interroger comment trouver l'équilibre
entre cette accueil de qualité et la
nécessité d'accroître l'offre
à la question des taux d'encadrement
vous apportez une réponse limpide
indiquant ces normes doivent être
considérés comme un plancher
réglementaire permettant d'assurer la
sécurité et non comme un optimum pour
rappel on parle de un professionnel sur
cinq enfants qui ne marche pas ou un
pour 8 pour les enfants qui marchent
ceci pour des questions de sécurité
votre proposition de changer ce
paradigme pour regarder ces taux
d'encadrement en termes de qualité me
paraît plus que nécessaire d'ailleurs
d'autres pays européens ont défini
d'autres normes d'encadrement si vous
avez d'ailleurs des conseils nous serons
ravis de les entendre vous incitez
également sur la qualification
insuffisante des personnels dès lors
comment parvenir à des standards de
qualité élevé et à même d'assurer
l'épanouissement de ses enfants
vous recommandez de renforcer les
contrôles et d'utiliser le financement
comme un levier en mettant en place des
contrats pluriels d'objectifs et de
moyens cela peut sembler pertinent mais
doit nous interroger en cas de non ou de
mauvaises exécution d'un setum quel
serait les conséquences pour les enfants
au-delà de ces deux sujets j'aurais deux
questions qui pensent la démocratie
interne des crèches tout d'abord vous
avez eu l'opportunité de vous interroger
ou d'interroger
avez-vous eu pardon le opportunité de
vous interroger ou d'interroger sur la
présence des conseils de crèche
obligatoires et d'autre part sur la
présence des parents dans ces conseils
seriez-vous également indiqué à la
délégation si vous avez connaissance de
contrôle de ces établissements opéré par
la PMI et leur nombre
ce constat de déficit de contrôle fait
écho au même constat que l'on peut
porter côté EHPAD et établissement pour
enfants
d'ailleurs ce matin un journal satirique
dénonce le fait que certains
départements et recours à des cabinets
privés à qui on donne notamment accès
aux données médicales des enfants pour
effectuer ces contrôles
l'ordonnateur on le voit ne peut pas
être en même temps prescripteur et
contrôleur je plaide donc pour une
instance de contrôle d'État dans tous
ces établissements quelle serait votre
sentiment sur ce projet
dernier élément de questionnement
avez-vous connaissance de situation
problématique concernant l'accueil
d'enfants situations de handicap
et enfin il nous faut également préciser
que la délégation a auditionné les
représentants des syndicats fédérations
des professionnels de la petite enfance
qui ont dressé le même constat un manque
de personnel un problème d'attractivité
du métier une formation insuffisante
mesdames et messieurs avant de passer la
parole à mes collègues vous proposez 38
recommandations outre les sujets précis
sur lesquels je vous interroge et
au-delà du chapitreage thématique de
votre rapport
pourriez-vous distinguer celles que vous
considérez comme prioritaire et comment
peuvent-elles être déclinés je vous
remercie et je vous laisse la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés nous allons
présenter quelques-uns des aspects
saillants de nos conclusions et nous
essaierons au fur et à mesure de
répondre aux questions que vous nous
avez adressées dans votre présentation
liminaire en effet pour le rappeler nous
avons analysé et envisagé dans ce
rapport tous les facteurs qui pouvaient
concourir à la qualité d'accueil dans
les établissements et pour préciser sur
le plan méthodologique ces critères de
qualité nous les avons pris très au
sérieux dans le sens où s'agissant de
jeunes enfants on ne peut pas considérer
que les critères de qualité sont de
simples critères
d'agrément de confort de qualité de
service comme ça pourrait l'être
davantage pour des établissements pour
les adultes en l'occurrence nous nous
situons bien sûr dans les périodes des
1000 premiers jours où la la plasticité
cérébrale des enfants est extrêmement
important et par conséquent quand les
critères de qualité se dégradent et bien
les effets sur le développement des
enfants aussi bien sur le plan de la
sécurité affective du développement
moteur ou cognitifs peuvent être
extrêmement extrêmement importants et
par conséquent pour pour le dire de
façon un petit peu claire quand en
raison d'une insuffisance de personnel
de taux d'encadrement en raison des
contraintes de gestion un enfant de
moins d'un an ou de moins de deux ans et
conduit à rester en pleurs à de
nombreuses reprises pendant des durées
importantes sans que des professionnels
puissent venir l'entourer ou prendre
soin de lui et bien ce sont des
conséquences qui peuvent être
importantes sur le développement
ces critères de qualité nous les avons
envisagés à partir de la littérature
scientifique et des consensus qui
existent actuellement à l'issue de
plusieurs décennies de recherche sur le
jeune enfant qui ont profondément
infléchi bouleversé la compréhension que
l'on pouvait avoir des besoins du jeune
enfant et de son fonctionnement à la
fois cérébrale sensorielle et le premier
constat que nous avons dressé c'est
qu'il y avait un écart très important
entre les conclusions de la de la
recherche le consensus scientifique qui
existe aujourd'hui sur les besoins du
jeune enfant et la façon dont la
politique publique avait été construite
et ce qu'on constatait comme pratique
dans l'accueil du jeune enfant
par conséquent ce qui est vraiment
structurant pour nous qui est un peu le
fil rouge de notre rapport c'est en
effet qu'il faut mettre les besoins de
l'enfant et l'intérêt de l'enfant comme
un objectif prioritaire de cette
politique publique la politique publique
c'est construite comme une réponse aux
enjeux d'égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les hommes comme objectif
de pleine emploi et ce sont des
objectifs tout à fait légitimes
évidemment pour permettre aux parents de
travailler mais les besoins du jeune
enfant n'ont pas été véritablement prise
en compte d'une façon suffisante dans la
construction de cette politique c'est
donc un aspect que vous rappeliez dans
votre propos liminaire c'est en cela que
nous indiquons que les objectifs ont été
portés sur l'aspect quantitatif et
beaucoup moins sur l'aspect qualitatif
et pour répondre à votre question sur
l'équilibre à trouver entre ces deux
aspects ce que nous indiquons dans le
rapport c'est que tant que l'on n'aura
pas répondu à l'objectif qualitatif
c'est à dire que les conditions de
travail ne seront pas meilleures que les
professionnels ne pourront pas faire
leur travail d'une façon qui soit
satisfaisante pour eux et en cohérence
avec leur valeur et bien les difficultés
d'effectif et les pénuries de personnels
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui ne
pourront pas être résolus et que par
conséquent les objectifs
de création de place seront bien sûr
extrêmement difficile à atteindre
donc nous voulons
souligner dans le rapport que nous
remettons au centre qu'il faut remettre
au centre de la politique du jeu
d'enfant les besoins de l'enfant
lui-même et en ce sens nous évoquons
également une réflexion qui doit être
conduite sur les rythmes et l'amplitude
d'accueil pour les enfants à l'heure
actuelle les enfants peuvent être
accueillis pour des durées extrêmement
longues dans un accueil collectif à un
âge particulièrement précoce et regarde
des comparaisons européennes nous
accueillons les enfants en accueil
collectif à un âge qui est
particulièrement faible et donc dans la
continuité du rapport des 1000 premiers
jours qui a été bien sûr piloté par
Boris Cyrulnik nous appelons à une
réflexion sur
l'allongement des congés parental enfin
paternelle maternelle d'une part et
congés par Auto d'autre part en
réfléchissant bien sûr dans cette
dynamique sur l'équilibre ibre dans la
prise de ces congés entre les femmes et
les hommes ce que le rapport des 1000
premiers jours avait déjà d'ailleurs
très bien fait puisque il avait montré
étude scientifique et européenne à
l'appui que si l'allongement de enfin la
meilleure rémunération de ce congé
parental était bien fait et que les
règles étaient bien pensées elles
favorisaient au contraire une meilleure
implication des pairs seconds parents
dans le dans la prime éducation des
enfants et une meilleure égalité entre
les sexes
donc ça c'est un c'est un aspect
vraiment structurant de notre réflexion
et s'agissant des constats que nous
avons fait à partir de là sur la qualité
d'accueil proprement dit dans les
établissements nous le disons dès la
synthèse de ce rapport nous avons
constaté une qualité d'accueil très
hétérogène vous le rappeliez nous avons
des professionnels qui sont très engagés
nous avons beaucoup d'établissements qui
portent des projets qui sont très
intéressants qui sont très porteurs mais
à ce jour dans beaucoup d'établissements
la qualité d'accueil ne peut pas être
garantie par les normes qui qui existent
aujourd'hui nous avons des groupes
d'enfants dans le nombre peut être bien
trop important parfois 20 25 voire 30
enfants qui sont dans une même pièce ce
qui était difficile en termes de stress
en termes de niveau sonore pour les
enfants comme pour les professionnels
des des taux d'encadrement vous leur
appeliez qui qui sont
insuffisants pour au regard du consensus
scientifique et des comparaisons
internationales à titre d'exemple
les pays européens effectivement que ce
soit le Danemark l'Italie le Royaume-Uni
sont à un adulte pour 3 enfants là où
nous sommes à 1 % ou un pour 8 selon
l'âge la Suède est à 1 pour 4 donc nous
sommes pour le dire très violemment à la
traîne et par ailleurs s'agissant du
niveau de formation et mon collègue
reviendra sur les ressources humaines
nous avons connu une trajectoire un
développement sur le plan des normes qui
a eu tendance à diminuer la part de
professionnels ayant un diplôme de
niveau 1 c'est à dire
infirmier de puéricultrice
puisqu'il s'agit essentiellement de
femmes éducatrices de jeunes enfants ou
auxiliaires de puériculture et nous
avons en réalité
actuelle une part majoritaire des
personnes qui prennent en charge
l'accueil effective des enfants qui sont
des personnes qui ont un CAP
petite enfance à EPE
qui est de niveau de formation
insuffisante au regard des exigences qui
s'attachent à l'accueil et que par
ailleurs pour 50% de ces personnes ces
cap sont préparés à distance en candidat
libre avec des organismes qui
éventuellement recrutent leurs candidats
sur Google ou autre moteur de recherche
et propose des formations au niveau
discutables donc
de façon générale sur le plan des
conditions qui vont permettre une
qualité d'accueil nous avons de
nombreuses inquiétudes que nous avons
exprimées dans ce rapport d'autant plus
que s'agissant des bâtiments des crèches
notamment dans le secteur public et
associatif nous avons beaucoup de
structures vieillissantes qui
demanderaient d'être revu aussi bien sur
le plan de la
condition même du bâtiment que sur le
plan de l'organisation intérieure pour
permettre que l'aménagement des locaux
soit en cohérence avec ce concept des
besoins des jeunes enfants ménage leur
possibilité de motricité d'intimité de
tranquillité etc donc à partir de là
effectivement nos grands axes de travail
sur cette question de la qualité et vous
parliez des mesures qui peuvent être
mises en place de façon rapide et bien
d'une part c'est sur le plan des normes
de faire monter progressivement le
niveau d'encadrement de
qualification des professionnels et de
faire descendre progressivement le la
taille moyenne
des groupes d'enfants et ça nous avons
conduit cette réflexion en disant il
faut l'inscrire dans les trajectoires de
la branche famine dans les exigences
qu'on fixe à la branche famille pour la
cause c'est à dire nous ne pourrons pas
relever de façon immédiate les normes
puisque nous sommes face à une pénurie
de professionnelle donc si on dit demain
il faut que les professionnels soient
plus qualifiés en plus grand nombre ce
sera un voeux pieux en revanche la
branche famille doit être positionnée
pour travailler avec les établissements
est-ce que progressivement on aille vers
ces normes de qualité et pas seulement
d'énormes de sécurité
le deuxième aspect important c'est que
nous avons
indiqué qu'il fallait structurer le
pilotage c'est-à-dire que les instances
de pilotage au niveau local et au niveau
territorial soit chargé véritablement
d'animer et de suivre la question de la
qualité alors actuelle aucun acteur ne
suit véritablement cette question comme
je le disais en entrée ce n'est pas une
question qui a été pleinement
identifiée et saisie dans la
construction de la politique et par
conséquent personne ne s'y investit
véritablement donc nous avons besoin que
dans les comités de départementaux de
services familles la mission qui soit
vraiment d'animation de la qualité soit
investie nous avons fait des
propositions très concrètes et cela
répond en partie à la question que vous
posiez sur la mise en oeuvre de la
formation alors bien sûr il y a la
formation des professionnels mon
collègue reviendra au niveau régional
etc mais au niveau territorial c'est
dans un comité départemental de service
aux familles il faut qu'il soit investi
de la mission d'assurer aussi de la
formation continue pour tous les
professionnels des établissements de son
territoire de l'analyse de la pratique
pour les directeurs et que il se
positionne comme acteur et ça ça peut
être fait très vite organisé des
séminaires des rencontres de la
formation continue en plus de ce qui est
proposé pour les gestionnaires faire
vivre la qualité d'accueil au niveau
territorial ça ça peut être investi et
le pilotage notre aussi structuré au
niveau national
nous avons un comité de filière de la
petite enfance nous avons proposé d'en
faire une première pierre pour bâtir un
comité national qui sera notamment
chargé de suivre et d'évaluer la qualité
de l'accueil
nous avons ensuite préconisé sur le plan
du contrôle non pas seulement de
renforcer les contrôles mais de réformer
la culture du contrôle c'est à dire que
le contrôle qui est réalisé par les PMI
et actuellement un contrôle qui est
centré sur les questions d'hygiène de
sécurité qui est un contrôle
essentiellement formel et donc nous
avons fait un certain nombre de
préconisations pour les accompagner dans
la construction d'une culture du
contrôle de la qualité de l'accueil qui
ne soit pas un contrôle administratif
sur pièces mais qui passe par
l'immersion dans les structures par
l'observation des enfants par les
entretiens avec les professionnels et
qui permettent de repositionner la PMI
sur ces questions et d'en faire une
force d'appui auprès de ces
établissements qui soit qui soit plus
importante nous avons posé la question
des données des données qui restent
assez parcellaires sur le nombre nombre
de contrôle régularité alors nous avons
travaillé en articulation avec la DGCS
qui a fait une enquête auprès des PMI
pour remonter précisément les rythmes de
contrôle
ça ne nous donne pas à ce jour de donner
ABSOLUMENT faire que nous pourrions
présenter ce que ça nous donne en
revanche c'est le fait que il y a des
normes qui sont affichées par les PMI
souvent de contrôler les établissements
privés une fois par an les associatifs
une fois tous les deux ans les privés
lucratent les publics pardon une fois
tous les trois ans
on peut discuter d'abord de ces
différences de régularité mais en tout
état de cause c'est énorme ne sont pas
respectées et nous avons dans plusieurs
départements vu des établissements y
compris le public qui n'avaient jamais
été contrôlés ou depuis des temps
immoraux donc nous devons réfléchir
alors évidemment ça pose la question des
moyens que l'on donne à CPMI elles n'ont
actuellement pas les moyens pour pour
faire cette activité de contrôle mais
aussi de savoir comment on les
accompagne pour transformer la culture
de contrôle et sur ce point il y a une
vigilance particulière que nous voulons
souligner c'est que il y a une demande
très forte des gestionnaires de crèches
pour que les exigences des PMI en
matière d'agrément de contrôle soit
unifiés sur le plan national ce qu'on
comprend puisque il y avait beaucoup de
disparités départementales donc les
gestionnaires se trouvaient dans une
situation où dans tel département on
leur disait oui dans tel autre
département le même point de passait pas
c'est mais il faut faire très attention
à ce que ça ne conduise pas à
transformer la PMI uniquement en
contrôleur qui viendrait voilà cocher
des cases dans des questionnaires sans
aucune capacité de jugement et de regard
du contrôleur sur la qualité dans
l'établissement c'est un point que nous
voulons indiquer et puis le dernier
élément
syndiquerait sur ces questions de la
qualité c'est d'avoir des financements
qui soient vraiment orientés vers vers
la qualité de l'accueil bon nous avons
montré qu'il y avait un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements qui étaient
attachés aux modalités actuelles de
financement d'une part parce que elle ne
contribuait pas
à renforcer la qualité de l'accueil
c'est une c'est une tarification à
l'activité qui n'est pas sensible à la
qualité ou au manque de qualité qu'il y
a dans les établissements d'autre part
parce qu'elle n'est pas claire sur qui
finance quoi par exemple entre les
collectivités et la branche famille pour
les établissements publics il n'y a pas
de répartition claire des financements
ce qui fait que quand la branche famille
met de l'argent en plus les
collectivités se retirent d'autant et
donc que les actions de la branche
famille et de la sécurité sociale en
faveur d'une augmentation des moyens des
établissements et bien franchement chou
blanc puisque le partenaire se retire
donc les financements ne sont pas
claires et par ailleurs la transparence
financière est insuffisante notamment
vis-à-vis des opérateurs privés sur
lesquels nous avons repéré un certain
nombre de zones de risques c'est pour
cette raison que nous avons proposé
effectivement des cépam vous l'évoquez
avec la recherche d'une solution qui
soit des financements où l'on sache ce
que l'on finance c'est-à-dire voilà
comment est-ce qu'on oriente sur des
objectifs de qualité vis-à-vis de
l'accueil
qui permettent à la fois d'assurer
l'équilibre budgétaire des
établissements qui aujourd'hui assez
compromis notamment pour les attentes
d'établissements associatifs et public
qui laisse en même temps une certaine
marge de manœuvre de responsabilisation
aux gestionnaire qui n'ont pas
l'impression de pourrir à chaque instant
derrière une heure faite non faite par
en venue pas venu qui puisse organiser
le budget de leur de leur établissement
et qui soit en même temps transparent
dans les rapports entre le financeur et
le gestionnaire on peut très bien avoir
nous l'avons indiqué des cépam entre les
financeurs et l'établissement et puis
ensuite pour les groupes des cépam entre
eux le financeur et le siège parce que
actuellement
les financeurs n'ont aucune visibilité
sur les flux financiers entre les sièges
des groupes et leurs établissements sur
la façon dont sont calculés les frais de
siège quelle est la clé de répartition à
quelle prestation afférente
correspondent ces frais de siège qui
sont imputés dans les comptes des
établissements donc c'est pour ça que
qu'on a fondé cette proposition de ces
pommes alors il faut ensuite que ce soit
creusé par les par les administrations
pour voir comment on le met en oeuvre
mais ça permettra de définir clairement
entre les différents partenaires parce
que dans le CPAM il y aura forcément les
collectivités d'une part la branche
famille de l'autre qui finance quoi et
ça il faut que ce soit bien défini pour
que on n'est pas ces mouvements que que
j'évoquais vous évoquez la possibilité
d'une mauvaise exécution ou d'une ou
d'une non exécution du Sepam mais en
même temps le CEPAM permet précisément
en ayant un vrai dialogue annuel et qui
ne porte pas uniquement sur les
questions financières si on investit
correctement mais sur les questions
d'objectif de de qualité d'avoir une
certaine visibilité sur la façon dont
dans les crédits sont orientés vers les
objectifs que l'on souhaite que l'on
souhaite atteindre c'est pour cette
raison que nous sommes allés dans cette
direction mais quel que soit les choix
qui seront faits par la branche famille
et par les autorités en matière de
financement c'est vraiment les objectifs
qu'il faut garder en tête ce sont c'est
vraiment de savoir où vont les
financements est-ce qu'ils vont vers la
qualité ou pas quelle est la
transparence financière et est-ce qu'on
sait clairement qui finance quoi entre
les différents partenaires il faudra
trouver une solution de financement qui
qui permettent de d'assurer que que ces
questions soient traitées
voilà pour les questions de qualité
évidemment
à côté de la dégradation de la qualité
nous avons et ça a été une partie
partant de notre rapport traité les
questions de prévention et de
signalement de la maltraitance et je
vais laisser la parole à ma collègue sur
ce point et nous reviendrons à la fin
avec mon collègue sur les questions de
ressources humaines
bonjour donc oui c'est vrai que c'est
notre travail était centré sur la
question de la maltraitance donc
il laisse agissait pour nous de d'aller
à la rencontre des établissements à la
rencontre des professionnels à la
rencontre des universitaires pour pour
percevoir véritablement les difficultés
qui pouvaient y avoir dans les crèches
en fait ben c'est tout simplement le
constat que l'on pouvait faire déjà
d'entrer pour toute structure tout
établissement qui accueille des
personnes vulnérables des personnes
dépendantes c'est inhérent à ce type
d'établissement quel qu'il soit à tout
âge de la vie il y a toujours des
risques de maltraitance et c'est vrai
que c'est important de rappeler que on
va développer le plus possible des la
bien traitance des de la qualité mais le
risque maltraitance est toujours là donc
il s'agit de le prendre en compte et
vrai on a mon collègue en parlait il y a
une notion un peu d'impenser pour les
établissements accueillant les enfants
un peu comme si parce qu'il y a
plusieurs professionnels il y a une
sorte de sécurité qui existe tout
simplement parce que les uns se
surveillent etc mais c'est la même chose
à tous les âges et ça devrait du coup
n'arriver à aucun âge de la vie et
aucune structure collective donc c'est
c'est important de le prendre en compte
de se dire que c'est possible c'est pas
pour ça que alors c'est vrai que les les
remontées les éléments que nous ont dit
les professionnels ont montré à quel
point c'est un secteur qui est
sensibilisé déjà à cette question est-ce
que une trame il ne nous aurait pas
signalé les choses donc il y a tout un
travail depuis une vingtaine d'années
qui est porté par la question des douces
violences bon c'est un terme qui peut
heurter mais qui est là pour énoncer les
risques
peut-être pas toujours les dénoncer par
contre mais en tout cas les énoncer et
prendre la mesure des choses donc on est
dans un secteur où les professionnels
souhaitaient vraiment exprimer les
difficultés qu'il rencontre et les faits
du quotidien qui peuvent survenir auprès
des enfants donc c'est remontées en fait
on a posé une question on a fait
plusieurs questionnaires auprès des
directeurs d'établissements des
professionnels et les professionnels ont
été 12000 à nous répondre plus de 12000
et un quart d'entre eux nous en dit on a
pu faire un petit pas de côté en leur
demandant s'ils avaient eu l'occasion de
travailler dans un établissement qu'il
considérait comme maltraitant donc c'est
un quart d'entre eux qui ont répondu OUI
et
2000 professionnels ont décrit des faits
donc qui
auxquels ils ont pu être témoins dont
ils ont pu être témoins donc
c'est c'est vraiment il faut on a
vraiment insisté sur le fait qu'il ne
faut pas partir de ces données en faire
des statistiques c'est simplement que
les personnes qui ont répondu à ces
questionnaires avaient besoin de
remonter ces éléments-là et de les
argumenter les présenter c'est vrai que
c'était des c'est un tiers des
établissements qui ont enfin au niveau
des directeurs qui ont répondu au niveau
des professionnels c'est sur l'ensemble
des départements y compris les tout
petits départements où il y a parfois
que 30 crèches ou 40 crèches etc donc
c'est important pour nous d'avoir ces
témoignages témoignages qui en fait
rejoignent les mêmes types de de
maltraitance que l'on peut
côtoyer malheureusement à tous les âges
de la vie aussi en termes de négligence
de de difficultés à répondre aux besoins
élémentaires
des enfants
la psaume l'absence de réponse à leur
peur le manque de respect du rythme des
enfants le manque de soins le des
problématiques de jugement de
manque de respect
et on va jusqu'à des violences des
violences physiques et bien sûr
psychologiques les punitions humiliantes
etc donc il y a des points qui sont plus
particulièrement remontés et qui ont
attiré notre attention parce que on a
fallu analyser ces 2000 commentaires qui
étaient là vous avez dans le dans le
rapport des petits extraits mais très
souvent c'était des c'était vraiment une
présentation complète c'était plusieurs
lignes pour expliquer les choses on a vu
le terme en particulier forçage forçage
alimentaire qui remonte qui était très
régulièrement mis en avant et on
s'aperçoit après dans les explications
de des professionnels qu'il s'agit aussi
des moments à risque dans la journée
dans un établissement c'est à dire que
ça rejoint les questionnements par
rapport aux financement il s'agit de
d'avoir le plus possible d'heures de
fait et de présence d'enfants dans
l'établissement même si on élargit le
temps d'ouverture de la crèche néanmoins
les les enfants sont surtout présents
aux mêmes heures et en particulier aux
heures de repas pour le repas de midi
donc c'est ça a été intéressant de voir
à quel point et puis de la sieste qui
suit avec aussi cette question de dire
allez on va on va pouvoir prendre plus
d'enfants demain parce que il y a
toujours des absents Yassi ala puis
après bah tout le monde est là il y a
pas assez de lit il y a pas assez de
soucis il y a pas assez de cela donc
voilà donc on a pu repérer concrètement
des éléments en fait de d'organisation
et on s'est beaucoup appuyé sur les
travaux de la commission nationale sur
la maltraitance qui rappelle clairement
que l'effet de maltraitance individuelle
prenne en grande outils leurs sources
dans les éléments de maltraitance
institutionnels et donc on a fait
l'exercice à partir des travaux de cette
commission en reprenant les les
causes en fait qui peuvent conduire à de
la maltraitance et on a retrouvé dans
les écrits des professionnels
des faits qui éclairent ces différentes
ces différents risques donc que ce soit
en termes de politique institutionnelle
de pratique managériales de
sous-effectif etc donc aussi en termes
de de représentation il faut dire que
tout va bien il faut faire que ce soit
au mieux et il faut éviter de dire que
etc donc il y a toute une culture la
culture de l'erreur la culture de de
partager les difficultés de parler de
d'échanger entre les professionnels et
avec leurs responsables sans être dans
le punitif parce que on entend beaucoup
aujourd'hui en réaction notre rapport à
Michel nous de toute manière on remercie
la personne qui a fait un problème qui a
été cause d'un problème non le problème
oui peut-être mais en tout cas
l'important c'est d'analyser pourquoi et
comment le fait ont pu survenir donc le
le
ces facteurs systémiques sont très
importants à prendre en compte et la
question aussi donc de la possibilité
d'en parler c'est la possibilité d'en
parler entre collègues dans pas dire tu
m'as l'air fatigué ça ne va pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe tu manques un peu
de patience aujourd'hui etc etc ça
paraît simple mais c'est des choses qui
n'existent pas toujours
et d'en parler entre collègues d'en
parler avec ses avec ses responsables et
de savoir que l'on contacte la PMI il
faut vraiment que ce soit que ce soit
une information qui soit clairement
donné à tous les professionnels que
après ce temps de d'échange entre
professionnels avec ses responsables il
y en a eu plusieurs commentaires nous
disant que il n'était pas entendu
parfois de leur responsable de savoir
que on peut s'y en faire une un
signalement quand on est un
professionnel à la à la PMI de la même
façon pour les parents il faut qu'ils
puissent avoir aussi le numéro de
téléphone des de la PMI locale c'est
vraiment localement ça doit se
travailler et donc là de la même façon
les parents savoir que d'abord on parle
aux professionnels puis on parle
aux responsables etc et c'est là aussi
si après tout cet élément ces éléments
on reste inquiets on a des doutes on
signale à la PMI c'était vraiment un
point important pour nous de d'insister
sur cette proximité et cette
connaissance de ses services et de ses
professionnels de qualité qui doivent
pouvoir répondre à ces problèmes voilà
donc je pense que c'était à peu près les
points que l'on voulait voir et c'est
vrai que ça reprend tous les thèmes vus
par mon collègue et en particulier la
question de la formation des
professionnels et je vais laisser mon
collègue Christophe
mesdames et messieurs les députés merci
alors je vais essayer d'être assez court
puisque j'ai compris qu'on avait une
demi-heure et qu'on est en train de
dépasser assez largement néanmoins les
sujets comment
très bien j'ai essayé de quand même
d'être synthétique simplement revenir
quand même sur un point abordé par mon
collègue quand il s'agissait des
contrôles et d'ailleurs ça rejoint une
question que vous avez posée madame la
présidence madame la Présidente pardon
d'abord il y a il faut pas oublier que
dans le contrôle de la qualité il y a
aussi dans les contrôles il y a aussi la
CAF qui intervient qui intervient sur la
performance sociale économique de
l'établissement mais qui a des données
qui sont malheureusement non exploités
par exemple
une consommation les consommables
combien une crèche consomme deux couches
de denrées alimentaires qui peuvent être
demain qui demain peut servir comme
indicateur de qualité de standards de
qualité pour avoir des points d'alerte
sur les zones de résident c'est des
choses vous parlez des choses très
simples à mettre en œuvre
sous réserve que je ne suis pas
informaticien et je tiens pas le devenir
mais voilà il y a peut-être une
complexité technique mais en tout cas
c'est des choses assez simples qui
permettent d'orienter les contrôles et
d'être beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
efficaces et d'amener toute la filière
aussi vers du progrès évidemment il y a
la question des moyens du contrôle ce
qui est si vous prenez fiscaux on a
parlé des programmes de contrôle des
établissements effectivement il y a du
déclaré mais il y a la réalité et la
réalité c'est aussi une question de
moyens humains dédiée à ses contrôles et
à la fois ce qu'on y met dans le
contrôle mais aussi moyen humain vous
prenez une ville comme Paris Paris
intra-muros c'est 870 crèches un peu
plus 870 crèches
en CAF à la cave de Paris c'est trois
ETP qui sont consacrés au contrôle des
établissements donc
voilà on peut imaginer tous les
contrôles intelligents que l'on souhaite
on voit bien qu'il y a un vrai sujet
aussi de moyens et de la nécessité aussi
de coordonner davantage les contrôles
entre les différents institutions que
sont la PMI et les CAF alors il y a une
expérimentation intéressante on a été
nous sommes allés en en Haute-Savoie à
Annecy où il y a une expérimentation qui
a été qui est en cours justement de
contrôle plus que concerté conjoint des
cafpmi sur ce territoire
nous en sommes qu'à la face une qui est
l'instruction commune des autorisations
par par la CAF et la PMI ça produit
énormément d'effets y compris dans
l'échange de pratique et et de donner
comme je viens de le dire il faudra
poursuivre cette cette expérimentation
au-delà de l'autorisation dans la vie de
l'établissement comment les les deux
services apprennent aussi avec des
cultures différentes avec des
prérogatives différentes à travailler
ensemble à se nourrir et et à amener
justement l'ensemble de la des
établissements vers cette trajectoire de
de progrès donc voilà il y a sans doute
cette expérimentation à redémulier et en
tout cas nous ce qu'on a pu qu'on
constater c'est que au moment de
l'autorisation de l'instruction
d'autorisation c'était vraiment un gain
de temps
pour tout le monde un gain de qualité
notamment en ayant recours avec des
prêts parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
qui ça a été différemment collègue qui
relève du contrôle bâtimentaire qui
prend beaucoup de place dans le contrôle
notamment des PMI et
le sans doute des moyens à mettre en
œuvre dès que ça analyser une partie de
ces contrôles bâtiment dentaires pour
que les choses soient les compétences à
PMI soient réellement mobilisées sur la
qualité de l'accueil de l'enfant au-delà
de les choses un peu plus un peu trop
normatives
cela rejoint aussi une autre question
madame la Présidente sur les sur les
sanctions sur comment on amène les les
crèches sur une trajectoire de progrès
pour être politiquement correcte nous ce
qu'on a pu constater c'est beaucoup ça
me permettra de faire un une passerelle
avec la question des ressources humaines
on a senti aussi beaucoup de direction
d'établissements publics privés
lucratif non lucrative
fatigué de et des pays aussi fatigué de
d'alerter sur un certain nombre de de
difficultés et comme au jour
d'aujourd'hui
comme vous le savez c'est le département
qui autorise la commune qui est
consultée alors les plus que consultés
quand elle finance évidemment mais qui
est consulté et qu'ensuite c'est le
préfet qui qui ferme l'établissement et
qu'entre ouvrir ou fermé il n'y a pas de
d'échelle de sanction vous imaginez bien
que fermer une crèche sur un territoire
c'est un problème vous l'avez souligné
la présidente politique parce que ce
sont aussi des familles que l'on prive
de solutions vers l'emploi vers la
formation et donc bien souvent les
pressions politiques sont fortes et que
des crèches qui devraient être fermés ne
le sont pas pour ces raisons donc c'est
aussi cette réalité qu'il faut qu'il
faut regarder en face et donner
justement un arsenal ce que l'on propose
de sanctions progressives d'astreinte de
mise sous contrainte de décrèches pour
que une progressivité de la sanction et
que la PMI puisse être mieux armé pour
amener encore une fois les
établissements à bouger et les
professionnels ça a été dit par ma
collègue sont vraiment en demande
on est dans une prise de conscience
collective qui fait que aujourd'hui les
professionnels sont
en attente d'un regard politique sur sur
leurs attentes un regard institutionnel
de l'État des collectivités sur leur
métier parce qu'ils sont la sensation
d'être d'être vraiment dans de grandes
difficultés voire même dans des
situations de d'usure professionnelle ou
de Burn Out alors évidemment
tout ça conduit à
une très grande volatilité des
professionnels on l'a dit il y a une
pénurie qui a été estimée dans une
enquête de la CAF de 10000 ETP manquant
pour faire fonctionner les crèches
actuelles et ça rejoint la remarque de
de mon collègue sur comment créer
200000 200000 places supplémentaires
alors que nous avons déjà un problème de
d'attractivité des métiers et de pénurie
des effectifs cette pénurie un impact
sur la vitesse d'établissements on l'a
vu dans dans tous les établissements et
ça c'est vrai quel que soit le mode de
gestion
des établissements ça a un impact sur le
management souvent les personnes de
crèche qui arrivent en responsabilité de
référent au directeur d’éta licences sur
des jeunes professionnels dont la
formation n'a pas été axée sur des
techniques de management et donc ils se
retrouvent dans un milieu complexe il
suffit de s'immerger un peu dans des
crèches pour se rendre compte de la
difficulté de ce métier c'est toujours
des équipes compliquées à manager ce
sont des professionnels jeunes et qui
sont face à des pionniers de
professionnels et donc à la fois
très mobilisé sur du recrutement
permanent
à la fois sur eux-mêmes pallier le
défaut professionnel dans
l'accompagnement des enfants et en même
temps ne pas être au rendez-vous
suffisant des temps d'échanges sur
l'analyse des pratiques de temps
d'échange sur ambilatéral avec
l'ensemble des collaborateurs et des
procès de ce métier et notamment ça a
été dit des jeunes professionnels une
grande part des professionnels qui
arrivent qui exercent désormais en
crèche sont des professionnels qui
bénéficient du CAP petite enfance sont
des professionnels qui bien souvent sont
insuffisamment formés ça a été dit le
diplôme est insuffisant il est formé
souvent à distance avec des personnes
qui sont qui arrivent en établissement
sans avoir tenu un bébé dans les bras et
que le du fait de la pénurie
professionnelle le management n'est pas
là pour étayer amener les professionnels
à s'intégrer dans une équipe et à
apprendre à apprendre un métier et donc
ça tout cela met évidemment ces
établissements en grande en grande
difficulté à cela évidemment des
concurrents exacerbées entre les
différents gestionnaires pour recruter
coûte que coûte les professionnels donc
un système de confiance exacerbée avec
des primes et là c'est on rejoint une
iniquité territoriale c'est-à-dire des
communes qui sont riches mon pouvoir
exercé un système de prime qui vont
mettre en difficulté d'autres d'autres
territoires
et
enfin je vais je vais quand même en
terminer sur le sur les sur les diplômes
donc il y a cette question de de la de
la souffrance au travail qui s'exerce au
sein des au sein des établissements on a
été extrêmement
voilà touché et étonné de voir à quel à
quel niveau de souffrance
professionnelle sont certains
établissements certains professionnels
je pense qu'il faut le dire et saluer
que malgré cela ils tiennent ils
tiennent vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente mais c'est important de le
dire parce que voilà notre rapport
peut-être peut paraître accablant mais
c'est important de dire que les
professionnels sont motivés qui a
évidemment un problème de formation
d'une part puisque la formation les
procès à diplômés viennent mon collègue
dédié à la fois de du secteur éducatif
avec les éducateurs jeunes enfants et du
secteur plutôt sanitaire une culture
sanitaire du côté des auxiliaires du
puériculture et donc c'est de cet
équilibre que que se crée un
savoir-faire des compétences au sein des
établissements et qui a un autre sens il
serait grand temps de développer un
socle commun de compétences du métier de
la petite enfance quel que soit l'entrée
par laquelle on arrive dans ces métiers
je reviendrai pas sur le cap qui est
évidemment insuffisant notamment dans un
secteur en pénurie de Bruxelles et
ensuite
quantitativement pardon il y a un
décroché entre le nombre de de diplômés
la création de place vous le verrez dans
des graphiques assez parlant si on prend
l'auxiliaire de les auxiliaires depuis
la culture de 2012 à 2000 à 2021 alors
que nous avons créé 30% de place
supplémentaires le nombre de diplômés
n'a augmenté que de 10% et quand je dis
augmenter 10% c'est qu'on ne sait pas si
c'est procès elles vont en crèche parce
que quand on est au tiers de
puériculture on peut aller aussi dans
d'autres établissements qui ne sont pas
de la petite enfance et pour les et pour
les éducateurs de jeunes en France et
c'est assez simple donc je le rappelle
30 % d'augmentation des places et on
produit l'appareil de formation produit
autant de Jo qu'il y a il y a 10 ans
donc c'est assez parlant pour
pour démontrer que il y a un effort de
formation alors le Président vous disiez
pour ces points là comment faire pour
aller vite
malheureusement il va falloir
beaucoup mobiliser dans la durée parce
que il va falloir du temps pour former
et là on a été surpris dans ce dans ce
dans ce secteur c'est le défaut de
données
grande difficulté à savoir des choses
très simples le nombre de professionnels
qui travaillent dans le secteur déjà ça
serait déjà pas mal les données
salariales ça a l'air médian salaire
moyen avec des professionnels qui sont
qui relèvent de huit conventions
collectives donc évidemment avec toutes
les disparités de classement vous pouvez
imaginer qui ne favorise pas non plus la
GPEC donc la gestion préle des emplois
et des carrières et donc les parcours
professionnels de ces professions et
donc on a défaut de données y compris
sur des données de qualité de vie au
travail et donc dans les mesures à
prendre en considération c'est déjà de
faire un diagnostic se dire quels sont
quantitativement et qualitativement quel
est l'état de la profession quels sont
l'état des métiers et par ailleurs pour
ce qui relève de la formation
nous avons interrogé évidemment les
régions qui sont aux manettes de fait de
leurs compétences sur la sur la
formation et il nous avons très peu ça a
été mentionné dans le rapport on a très
peu d'études de taux d'insertion dans
l'emploi et donc on ne sait pas où
travaille les professionnels à 6 mois ou
un an est-ce qu'elles sont en crèche ou
est-ce qu'elles sont elles sont ailleurs
et le système fonctionne je mettrai les
choses entre guillemets mais un peu à
l'aveugle et donc on produit alors en
plus avec des effets conjoncturels par
exemple la crise sanitaire a mobilisé
fortement les régions sur les
professions de santé ce qui était ce qui
était normal au détriment souvent de ces
professions qui sont dans ce ni dans le
social dans le métier ou sociales qui
sont confisés considérés un peu
différemment et donc il y a lieu là de
faire un gros effort de formation alors
on a essayé de l'estimer sur les
quelques études que nous avons pu avoir
en termes de taux d'insertion donc c'est
vraiment à prendre en considération de
manière très prudente mais d'augmenter
les efforts de formation de 30% pendant
3 ans en gros c'est une année de
formation pleine et entière pour
simplement permettre de revenir aux
effectivement quand ce qui veut dire
qu'on arrête l'hémorragie et que de on
ne crée pas de place en tout cas on n'a
pas les Brussels pour pouvoir amener ces
nouvelles plages et pour avoir plus de
là aussi pour puisque vous cherchez
aussi des mesures dans ce tableau un peu
complexe de mesurer immédiate à mettre
en oeuvre on a dans on a désormais un
schéma départemental qui est désormais
obligatoire nous proposons de rendre
causables d'une part pour réguler
l'offre sur le territoire puisque
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il y a on en
parlera sans doute dans les questions
que vous aurez à nous poser mais on a
des acteurs qui investissent des
territoires et y compris si le maire ou
la mer c'est un avis défavorable rien ne
s'oppose quand on il s'agit notamment
des micro-crèches à ce que la personne
le gestionnaire s'installe et donc ça
peut venir déséquilibrer des
établissements privés privés Luc ou
publics qui fonctionnent mais qui se
retrouvent en concurrence
et donc déjà ça permettrait de réguler
l'offre et par ailleurs ça serait
puisque le sujet la formation aussi
prescriptif en termes de formation
puisqu'on saurait le nombre de places à
créer dans tel territoire et donc le
nombre de professionnels à former dans
tel territoire sur les 5 années puisque
en général c'est c'est la cyclicité du
du de ce type de ce type de schéma donc
voilà assez rapidement
résumé les questions plus de ressources
humaines et peut-être un mot de
conclusion de de mon collègue merci
juste avant qu'on conclut pour vous
donner les éléments à deux questions
que vous ayez sur la démocratie dans les
crèches d'une part nos questionnaires en
faire remonter qu'à peu près un quart
des établissements avaient un conseil de
crèche ou une instance de ce type qui
permettait d'associer les parents mais
les remontées sont tiède sur le
fonctionnement de ces instances soit
parce qu'on a de tout petits
établissements notamment les
micro-crèches je suis quand même
difficile
étant donné le nombre de familles de
beaucoup mobiliser ce que mettent en
avant les professionnels et les
directeurs d'établissements c'est que
c'est pas nécessairement par ce type
d'instance que ça va passer dans le ce
qui est difficile d'immobiliser les
parents c'est plutôt voilà par
l'organisation au quotidien de temps
voilà de café avec les parents de me
rendre compte ne m'ont les parents
viennent dans la crèche plutôt que par
des instances formelles et à ce titre un
élément sur lequel nous avons beaucoup
insisté c'est la question de la
transmission les transmissions matin
soir que font les professionnels avec
les parents qui là aussi il faut faire
bouger un petit peu les pratiques ça
reste très
sanitaire disons dans son dans son
modèle
l'investissement de ce moment pour avoir
vraiment de l'accompagnement la
parentalité des conseils de un peu de
temps d'explications sur ce qui se
passait avec l'enfant sur son stade de
développement là on peut on peut
progresser un petit peu et puis vous
nous aviez posé une question sur
l'accueil des enfants en situation de
handicap alors nous n'avons pas eu le
temps et les moyens de faire des
investigations précises sur ces
questions et en particulier sur les
crèches à VIP en revanche ce qui nous
remonte de nos questionnaires où nous
avions à peu près un
directeur d'établissement sur deux qui
accueillait vous pouvez accueilliamment
un autre un enfant en situation de
handicap leur problème principal que
dans leur remontée notamment lors d'un
Batim c'est la formation
de leur professionnelle ils estiment que
la professionnelle sont souvent en
difficulté
n'ayant pas suffisamment étayer sur la
sur l'accueil du handicap et puis le
fait que l'accueil d'enfants en
situation de handicap y compris
lorsqu'il s'agit de handicaps lourd
n'est pas ne va pas conduire un
renforcement du nombre de personnels or
si on accueille des enfants qui ont des
handicaps très lourds notamment qui
peuvent pas aider m'enlever les soulever
les manipuler etc c'est pratiquement du
1 pour 1 et par conséquent soit en fait
l'accueil est refusé par la structure
soit l'accueil va déstabiliser
l'activité du groupe ou une pète
satisfaisante enfin c'est un petit peu
la difficulté qui nous est remontée mais
nous n'avons pas eu n'a pas mené
d'investigation approfondie sur cette
question précise
merci beaucoup pour ces propos si on
propose c'est qu'on est déjà un collègue
par groupe qui puisse vous poser une
question mais chaque collègue je suis
comme d'habitude assez pénible je vais
vous demander voilà compte tenu en plus
du temps si d'autres collègues au-delà
des responsables de groupe veulent
parler de vous limiter à deux minutes
madame Nicole dubrechyra pour le groupe
Renaissance
pardon rapport sollicité par le ministre
Jean-Christophe Kombat qui illustre les
problématiques interrogations et manque
auxquelles sont confrontées
professionnelles et les établissements
d'accueil des jeunes enfants sur des
informations importantes du quotidien
des professionnels sur la législation en
vigueur je voudrais quand même commencer
mon propos pour accorder mon soutien aux
professionnels qui accueillent les
enfants et les remercier de leur
engagement et de la qualité de leur
travail afin de ne pas jeter le propre
sur l'ensemble de la profession les
témoignages anonymes que vous rapportez
font état des violences négligences
forçage alimentaire la presse en effet
écho et ça suscité moi légitime à la
suite de ces révélations y a-t-il eu une
libération de la parole ou davantage de
signalements qui ont été déposés par les
parents notamment d'autre part
l'augmentation du travail des femmes a
rendu nécessaire la création et
l'ouverture de structures de garde et
l'augmentation du nombre de places de ce
fait s'est installé une logique
quantitative plus que qualitative
comment retrouver un équilibre élourdir
le fonctionnement de ces structures la
mise en place récente du référentiel
national pour l'aménagement intérieur
des crèches et la charte nationale de
qualité d'accueil du jeûne enfant
répondit à ce besoin de pilotage et
permettra-t-il l'harmonisation de la
qualité de l'accueil quel est votre avis
sur la pratique de certification type
kalier enfance et sa généralisation
concernant les professionnels ce secteur
fait face un manque d'attractivité vous
l'avez dit écart entre les valeurs et
les capacités à faire absence de
valorisation financière charge de
travail sans compter les départs en
retraite prévu qui font craindre une
accentuation de cette pénurie actualiser
la formation initiale est une nécessité
développer la formation continue tout au
long de la vie professionnelle contribue
à mieux pour voir ses postes à fidéliser
les personnes sur ceci de même que les
évaluations diffusion et échangent de
bonnes pratiques sont une gage un gage
de qualité de compétences mais comment
faire bénéficier les petites structures
de plus en plus nombreuses sans entraver
leur fonctionnement faute de
remplacement et un dernier point sur le
taux d'encadrement qui est cité
effectivement un enfant un professionnel
pour 5 enfants qui ne marche pas ou un
pour 8 les professionnels souhaitent une
évolution de ce taux et suggère d'autres
scénarii pouvaient vous préciser les
orientations plus importantes de ce
rapport je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour le groupe
rassemblement national madame parmentier
merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs merci pour le travail
considérable que vous avez réalisé ce
que vous nous dites ce que vous venez de
nous dire est affolant et les verbatimes
de votre rapport sont glaçants quel père
ou qu'elle maire en confiance son bébé
aux soins des employés de la crèche le
matin avant de partir travailler peut
imaginer qu'il le livre pour toute la
journée à un calvaire pareil
votre rapport témoigne de l'échec
d'Emmanuel Macron alors que le service
public de la petite enfance était l'une
de ses plus importantes promesses de
campagnes présidentielles et devait être
le chantier majeur de son début de
quinquennat je parle du quinquennat
précédent celui de 2017 aucune réponse
satisfaisante n'a été apportée en 6 ans
puisqu'on en est là sa politique de la
petite enfance a mis l'accent sur la
création de place au détriment des
conditions de travail de ceux qui
accueillent les tout-petits on voit les
résultats si votre rapport choque ne
sert pas à réformer les conditions
d'accueil de la petite enfance rien ne
les réformera compte tenu de l'urgence
de ces réformes plus urgentes que la
réforme des retraites soit dit en
passant et de la lenteur politique et
administrative à quel horizon
pensez-vous que l'on puisse espérer une
amélioration que pensez-vous de la
promesse de Olivier Véran reprenant
celle d'Elisabeth borne annonçant 200000
places de crèches supplémentaires alors
qu'il manque plus de 10000
professionnels et que l'urgence est de
mettre fin à la possibilité de recruter
du personnel non qual ifié plusieurs
syndicats de la petite enfance
recommandent une allocation suffisamment
attractive pour permettre un réel choix
quant au mode de garde des enfants pour
l'un ou l'autre parent que pensez-vous
de cette proposition
votre rapport suggère d'accorder au
président du conseil départemental un
pouvoir de sanction allant de
l'injonction à la fermeture comment
pensez-vous que cette mesure sera
accueillie par les employeurs et
professionnels de la petite enfance je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour le groupe des
Républicains monsieur portier
non je vous reprends après promis je
j'ai sauté une ligne ou allez-y je vous
en prie
j'ai sauté une ligne veuillez m'en
excuser je
monsieur Perceval gaillard
j'ai sauté la ligne excusez-moi il y a
aucun problème merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs tout d'abord effectivement
tient aussi à vous féliciter au nom du
groupe pour ce pour ce rapport qui fait
froid dans le dos et notamment en termes
de financièreisation du secteur on va
certainement y venir avec les collègues
qui vont prendre la parole moi je tenais
à tirer votre attention sur la situation
de la petite enfance dans les outre-mer
et à la Réunion en particulier puisque
c'est un point mort comme souvent des
politiques publiques et y compris des
rapports qui sont liés à la petite
enfance chez nous à la Réunion on a un
taux on a un taux de 20 points de retard
par rapport à l'Hexagone en termes de
taux d'équipement il nous manque environ
un minima 3000 places
d'accueil pour la petite enfance la
réponse du gouvernement c'est
d'assouplir les conditions d'embauche du
personnel c'est-à-dire en gros et il
faut être très clair d'accueillir dans
nos crèches des personnels non formées
donc à partir du 31 août ça va venir
très vite le secteur de la petite
enfance pour embaucher des personnes non
diplômées par le biais de de dérogation
et sur certaines conditions donc moi
j'ai plusieurs questions d'abord
globalement quelle piste pour rattraper
le retard structuré dans les outre-mer
si un rappel que les enfants
ultramarins ont le droit au même
condition d'accueil que les enfants sur
le sol hexagonal deuxièmement quel
danger quand on embauche des personnels
non formés et quel paradoxe avec ce que
vous dites dans votre rapport puisque
vous assistez bien sur le fait qu'il
faut plus et mieux former les personnels
en fait et ensuite troisième point j'ai
rencontré les professionnels de la
pouponnière la seule pouponnière dans le
département de La Réunion donc là pour
venir accueille des enfants placés il
s'agit de la protection de l'enfance ils
font remonter un gros problème en termes
de taux d'encadrement tout à l'heure
vous avez dit que c'est un miracle que
certaines équipes puissent arriver
finalement à mettre en à faire leur
travail là très clairement on est dans
un miracle au niveau de la pouponnière
de la Réunion j'imagine que c'est une
situation qui est largement qui existe
aussi dans la situation enfin au niveau
de l'Hexagone donc pour au niveau du
taux d'encadrement des pouponnières qui
est très faible quelle préconisations
vous faites pour permettre un meilleur
taux d'encadrement je vous remercie
merci beaucoup et encore toutes mes
excuses du coup cette fois-ci pour
républicain monsieur portier merci
Madame la présente madame messieurs
merci pour pour vos propos évidemment le
rapport est né dans un contexte
particulier
qui interpelle aussi bien le député du
Rhône que je suis puisque c'était suite
au décès d'un bébé de 11 mois à Lyon et
aussi évidemment le jeune papa et c'est
vrai que les froid pour la population
est vraiment sidérant on a du mal à
imaginer des drames pareilles dans un
établissement et l'une des réponses
comme vous le rappelez c'est évidemment
de relever le niveau de qualification et
de formation des travailleurs dans ces
structures et notamment de remplacer le
cap par un diplôme de niveau 4 comme
vous le proposez avec des formations aux
exigences renforcées
la question est la suivante est-ce que
d'élever le niveau d'exigence
ne pourrait pas aggraver les difficultés
qu'on a de recrutement est-ce que on n'a
pas un risque d'effet pervers même si
j'entends bien l'intention de louable
que je peux partager tout à fait par
ailleurs est-ce que ça pourrait pas
asphyxier ce que c'est la bonne
stratégie et est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
arrivez à évaluer ce risque là puis ma
deuxième question
porte sur l'intégration du handicap dans
ces dans ces structures
le décret du 30 août 2021 relatif aux
assistants maternels aux établissements
d'accueil de jeunes enfants est venu
créer et préciser le rôle du référence
santé et accueille inclusif au sein de
chaque AJE poussez aussi à l'aménagement
des locaux pour les rendre accessibles
intégré dans le projet d'établissement
les dispositions prises pour l'accueil
d'enfants présentant handicap et je n'ai
vu aucun élément dans votre rapport
concernant l'accueil justement des
enfants en situation de handicap dois-je
en conclure que ce décret est appliqué
sans manquement et sans difficulté et
est-ce que le personnel est toujours du
formé pleinement à vos yeux pour
accueillir des enfants en situation de
handicap afin de prévenir précisément et
maltraitance je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour le groupe socialiste
qui s'appelle Santiago
merci madame la Présidente docteur
monsieur mesdames chers collègues je
vous remercie bien évidemment pour votre
éclairage sur ce rapport dont nous vous
remercions bien évidemment rapport qui
est éprouvant et en même temps essentiel
pour éclairer la situation et l'urgence
d'y répondre les froid pour toutes les
familles qui ont eu accès à cette
information médiatique et bien
évidemment au député de la nation que
nous sommes et j'oserait dire aussi à la
grand-mère que je suis de petit bébé qui
vont en crèche je note particulièrement
la mère constat que la politique
d'accueil du jeune enfant et puis mettre
le confort de l'enfant accueilli par
essence vulnérable au second plan vous
le dites dans votre rapport privilégiant
des logiques quantitatives et comptables
je veux saluer à cet instant et je le
fais pour plusieurs raisons même si je
veux aller vite j'ai deux trois petites
choses à dire quand même c'est qu'en
fait j'ai été mes adjointe de la petite
enfance pendant 20 ans sujet que je
maîtrise totalement
et je ne me retrouve évidemment pas dans
non pas votre rapport parce que votre
rapport fait le constat mais j'ai eu la
chance de mener des politiques publiques
extrêmement avancées sur la question des
enfants et heureusement répondre à des
enjeux essentiels de la formation du
personnel et surtout je voudrais à ce
titre vous poser quelques questions
parce que comme j'ai vu l'évolution
sociétale et les politiques publiques
prendre des décisions je me rappelle
très très bien quand j'étais mère
adjoint je me suis mobilisée contre la
réforme du décret Morano de dinde moralo
et à l'époque notre consigne c'était pas
de bébé à la consigne c'était le slogan
des manifestations j'y ai participé mais
tous les personnels de la petite enfance
en participé et en fait c'est le
commencement de la déréglementation de
la petite enfance et je voudrais pour le
coup j'aimerais que ouvertement et
publiquement on dise aujourd'hui s'il y
a une responsabilité majeure sur les
décisions qui ont été prises à ce
moment-là parce qu'à ce moment-là on
pouvait faire plus de 20% de
suroccupation pour les enfants
dérèglementés les professionnels avec
des emplois comme vous l'avez dit qui
était donc plus obligatoire sous la
forme des mini crèches et donc je pense
qu'il y a des responsabilités sur
lesquelles nous devons revenir et je
vais sur les modifications des
personnels il y a beaucoup à faire mais
j'aimerais entendre votre réponse merci
beaucoup
madame Lebon pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente docteur
messieurs je veux saluer le travail
important que vous avez effectué le
drame survenu à Lyon en juin dernier a
créé c'est vrai une véritable onde de
choc et nos territoires ultramarins sont
touchés par les mêmes problématiques
difficultés à recruter des personnels
formés et motivés ce qui conduit à un
manque d'effectif et à des conditions de
travail compliquées et ce sont nos
enfants qui ont pâtissent je regrette
qu'aucun territoire d'outre-mer
n'apparaissent dans ce rapport aucun
sauf sur les cartes montrant justement
des problématiques importantes en Guyane
ou en Martinique les questionnaires ont
sans doute été transmis aux structures
ultramarines mais aucun déplacement n'a
été fait sur le terrain vous avez
pourtant visité certains départements
qui subissent une forte pénurie de
personnel d'autres qui semblent moins
inquiétées ce choix est varié est
intéressant mais ne concerne que
l'hexagone et pourtant tout ne va pas
bien dans le secteur de la petite
enfance dans les outre-mer
selon le rapport de mars de mars dernier
sur les violences faites aux mineurs en
outre-mer dont je suis co-rapporteur
dans les outre-mer le taux de couverture
du service public dans la petite enfance
est inférieur à la moyenne nationale
ainsi en Guadeloupe par exemple s'auto
de couverture et de 38% contre 58% en
hexagone selon le dernier rapport de
l'Observatoire national de la petite
enfance en 2019 en hexagone 21 enfants
de moins de 3 ans sur 100 peuvent
bénéficier d'une place en accueil
collectif contre 18,1 sur 100 dans les
dromes toutes les structures doivent
faire face à une pénurie de personnel et
sont particulièrement confrontés à leur
rotation fin de citation à la Réunion un
seul établissement de formation propose
30 places d'auxiliaires puéricultrice
chaque année trop peu pour absorber le
turn-over important dans un territoire
de plus de 800 000 habitants dans les
outre-mer le manque de place de
formation est l'un des principaux
problèmes l'offre limitée implique alors
de se rendre dans l'Hexagone ce qui
freine encore plus des jeunes déjà peu
attirés par les professions la petite
enfance les spécificités des Outre-mer
mérité Infocus un déplacement sur le
terrain pour mieux comprendre leurs
enjeux mais aussi pour inclure nos
populations et nos professionnels de la
petite enfance leur montrer l'intérêt
des autorités alors pour quelle raison
aucun déplacement en outre-mer n'a-t-il
été prévu dans le cadre de ce rapport je
vous remercie
merci Madame Lebon dont je salue avec
ces deux corps rapporteurs le travail
sur la protection des enfants en
outre-mer si vous ne l'avez pas encore
regardé je vous invite à le regarder je
vais faire une petite entorse je vais
donner la parole à Michel Peron qui doit
s'absenter mais qui était l'auteur d'un
rapport sur les PMI et je pense que
avant qu'elle s'absente c'est
intéressant qu'on est son éclairage
bonjour Docteur Messieurs chers
collègues justement je rebondis sur ce
qu'a dit 1 2 de vous sur l'importance du
contrôle PMI Protection Maternelle
Infantile sur donc son renforcement
autre que bâtimentaire et sanitaire je
pense oui c'était une de mes
préconisations vous avez parlé de la CAF
la CAF pourrait-elle c'est une
proposition que je vous fais
et je pourrai pas malheureusement
entendre la réponse mais madame la
Présidente me l'a rapportera pourrait-on
demander à la CAF de contrôler le
bâtiment terre et le sanitaire ma foi et
et laissez à la PMI donc l'entière
responsabilité du contrôle et du suivi
ce qui n'est fait comme vous l'avez dit
pas aujourd'hui de façon correcte et
voilà que que la PMI vraiment
s'occupe de l'enfant de son
environnement des professionnels qu'il
accueillent et je rajouterai que pour
toute structure de la micro-crèche à la
crèche qu'elle soit privée
associative ou public qu'il y ait au
moins une infirmière puéricultrice un
personnel de santé donc infirmière
puéricultrice ensuite les autres
personnels évidemment formés et je suis
actuellement d'accord pour qu'il y ait
une formation renforcée pour les pour
les pour les e parce qu'ils sont
capables de s'occuper des enfants mais
des petits enfants et donc ils leur font
une formation très particulière c'est
tout ce que j'avais à dire merci de
votre présence et merci surtout pour le
travail effectué et je rejoindrai mes
collègues d'outre-mer parce que comme
madame le Président le sait
l'outre-mer en particulier certains de
nos départements posent vraiment une
problématique
importante merci je vous laisse répondre
assez rapidement parce que je pense je
si d'autres collègues veulent intervenir
qui sont pas encore intervenir vous me
faites signe que je vous note
oui alors que quelques quelques éléments
rapides la question nous a été posée de
l'horizon temporelle des évolutions
l'horizon temporelle majeur ça va être
celui de la nouvelle convention
d'objectifs et de gestion avec la CNF
avec la branche family qui doit être
quitter actuellement en cours de
négociation qui va donc entrer en
vigueur pour les cinq prochaines années
je pense que c'est sur cet Horizont
temporelle de la coche que de les
modifications les plus importantes
peuvent être pensés pour que la branche
famille accompagne accompagne les
changements les plus importants et parmi
eux nous avons évoqué effectivement
l'allocation pour les les congés
parentaux donc nous nous sommes alors
dans la continuité du rapport des 1000
premiers jours d'ailleurs pour ces
allocations soient plus courtes et mieux
rémunérées et nous nous sommes référés
pour le suffrage au rapport
de la PLFSS pour la PLFSS de la Cour des
comptes en 2022 qui a proposé un
chiffrage budgétaire de ces éléments et
différents scénarios pour avoir
précisément des congés parentaux qui
soient donc mieux mieux rémunérés pour
pour les pour les deux parents sur le
plan de la
de la certification qui a été également
évoquée
de revenir sur la les questions de la
Charte mais ces certifications
présentent des intérêts mais nous avons
des points de vigilance particuliers le
premier c'est que il faut quand même
qu'il y ait une démarche qui soit aussi
portée par le pilotage national parce
que nous avons des initiatives qui
viennent un petit peu de diverses
sources pour créer des types de
certifications qui peuvent avoir leur
intérêt mais
l'efficacité n'est pas absolument
prouvée et surtout surtout
il faut qu'on évite d'entrer dans des
processus de certification qui en
réalité
certifie l'existence de protocoles parce
que surtout les domaines
sociaux médico-sociaux et la puissance
n'est pas préservée on va en permanence
certifier et vérifier l'existence de
protocole de documentation et en fait on
est en train de de certifier la qualité
de l'appareil administratif de la
structure alors ce n'est pas
évidemment sans importance ou sans effet
mais c'est la même chose que quand on
dit il faut passer à une culture du
contrôle de la qualité de l'accueil pour
la PMI c'est-à-dire est-ce que c'est un
point de vigilance particulier qu'il
faut avoir il faut qu'on regarde
concrètement comment ça se passe pour
l'accueil et pas uniquement au niveau de
ces de ces protocoles
[Musique]
et puis sur le vous avez posé des
questions sur le taux d'encadrement donc
là aussi nous avons repris n'ont pas
fait de nouvelles propositions par
rapport au rapport de 1000 premiers
jours puisqu'il y avait un consensus de
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
et professionnelle sur ce plan donc
c'est 1% pour l'ensemble des enfants
c'est à dire que nous ramenons
un pour 8 vers le 1 pour 5 et donc nous
augmentons le nombre de personnels ce
qui permettra donc à l'ensemble des
personnels d'avoir un petit peu de de
respiration et je dirais à ce propos
puisque les interventions ont commencé
sur ce thème que évidemment nous avons
mon collègue a salué également tout à
l'heure sur le plan de des ressources
humaines le l'engagement des
professionnels nous nous pensons mais
évidemment nous sommes les auteurs de ce
rapport donc peut-être nous sommes nous
pas tout à fait objectif mais nous
pensons que ce rapport n'a pas jeté le
propre sur la profession et nous en
voulons pour preuve le fait que vous
avez parlé de libération de la parole
tous les retours et toutes les
expressions des professionnels dans
l'espace public ou d'ailleurs vis-à-vis
de nous ont été de dire que les constats
qui avaient été faits rejoignaient leur
réalité nous pensons que c'est important
d'avoir porté cette parole pour que
cette réalité soit soit reconnue et donc
cette libération elle a elle a en partie
eu lieu avant de laisser
la parole
vous nous avez interrogé sur sur les
territoires d'outre-mer
effectivement ce sont des territoires ce
qu'elles nous avons noté dans les
chiffres des difficultés particulières
sur les sur les taux d'équipement
nous n'avons pas tellement de réponses à
vous apporter si ce n'est que
malheureusement nous avons conduit ce
travail entre le début du mois de
septembre et la fin du mois de décembre
à savoir 4 mois et que voilà nous
n'avons pas eu le temps de faire ces
déplacements et effectivement ça aurait
été un travail intéressant
d'aller voir et important d'aller voir
ce que ce qu'il en est dans la situation
des Outre-mer
l'inspection générale publie par
ailleurs de nombreux rapports sur ces
situations
mais maintenant pas eu le temps de le
faire dans le dans le cadre de ce
travail et peut-être puisque vous
interrogez sur la pouponnière
évidemment ça n'était pas l'objet de
notre rapport il est vrai que dans
l'Aide Sociale à l'Enfance les taux
d'encadrement ne sont pas définis
tu vas faire l'objet d'un décret de la
DGCS mais pas de définition à ce jour
oui je voulais aussi peut-être répondre
à la question donc du qualitatif
quantitatif et la référence au
référentiel bâtimentaire que vous avez
cité et à la charte nationale d'accueil
du jeune enfant c'est vrai que alors
déjà peut-être pour commencer par
rapport à la charte nationale du jeune
d'accueil du jeune enfant c'est un
travail extrêmement intéressant c'est
vrai que la charte est dans la
réglementation c'est aujourd'hui
opposable et cette charte mérite d'être
mieux connue elle est connue simplement
à travers ses 10 principes
ces 10 grands principes ce qui est déjà
une chose mais il y a un arrêté qui
détaille véritablement ce que l'on
attend de la qualité dans un
établissement donc on a une base qui est
très intéressante pour pour construire
un référentiel pour l'ensemble de la
profession et je vous engage à regarder
en particulier dans cet arrêté alors ça
serait bien qu'il soit diffuser
autrement qu'à travers un arrêté ce
n'est pas trop pas engageant d'aller
lire un arrêté mais les principes 8 et 9
donc qui touche à la fois sur
l'environnement beau sein et propice à
mon éveil c'est la façon dont les grands
principes de le présenter mais vous
verrez c'est très détaillé et la
l'importance de de travailler de prendre
du temps entre professionnels et c'est
là c'est la 9e le 9e principe travailler
auprès des tout-petits nécessitent des
temps pour réfléchir ce documenter
échanger on a vraiment insisté dans la
prise en compte du temps passé
au sein de des établissements du temps
avec les enfants et du temps hors la
présence des enfants pour vraiment
travailler à la qualité et à l'échange
de pratique et c'est vraiment un point
très important pour ce qui est de la
donc vraiment on a voilà il y a des
points très aussi sur lesquels
s'appuyait et donc construire un
référentiel on a souhaité que peut-être
donc au niveau national il puisse y
avoir un référentiel qualité qui puisse
se bâtir à partir de cette base qui est
très intéressante pour ce qui est du
référentiel bâtimentaire en effet c'est
une avancée en même temps on a bien
remarqué la question de la problématique
la problématique plutôt de la qualité de
vie au travail des professionnels à
savoir que le référentiel bâtiment terre
n'exige pas d'avoir une salle de repos
d'avoir un lieu pour manger pour avoir
un minimum on a eu à visiter des crèches
où il n'y a pas de du tout de mobilier
pour adultes
où les gens sont assis par terre mangent
par terre
ils n'ont pas de lieu pour se changer
enfin on a vraiment là un gros gros
travail à faire et ce ne sont pas des
vieilles structures obligatoires voilà
c'est tout type de structure c'est pas
obligatoirement des choses en des des
voilà des organisations anciennes voilà
donc c'était un point important vous
avez bien fait de nous le signaler donc
par rapport aux enfants handicapés le
référentiel bâtimentaire tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui on était dans un département
très rural la PMI nous disait que il y a
presque les deux tiers des crèches qui
ne passeront pas les 2026 dans le sens
de c'est pour jusqu'à 2026 la mise aux
normes donc avec l'accessibilité en
particulier de la crèche qui est demandé
et il y a énormément de bâtiments qui ne
sont pas aux normes aujourd'hui et donc
2026 va vite arriver et ça sera
difficile
et pour pour la question donc des
référents santé c'est vrai que on a eu
assez peu de de remontées mais c'est
vrai que c'est un point très important
je crois que c'est important de rappeler
que le référent ne doit pas travailler
en visio à distance c'est une vraie
présence auprès des équipes et des
enfants parce qu'on a entendu beaucoup
de projets où en effet on nous a dit oui
oui on va mettre en place le référent
pour parce qu'il n'y a plus les médecins
de crèche comme vous le savez ou pas
mais voilà donc ces référents santé
insertion donc les textes le disent mais
on l'a important de le rappeler ça n'est
pas un travail à faire à distance
voilà
peut-être un mot si nous avons un peu de
temps pour répondre notamment à cette
question en fait de qualité ou quantité
ou monsieur le député vous le soulignez
sur le fait de relever un certain nombre
de niveaux de standard de qualité de la
formation et de remettre finalement des
établissements en difficulté qui ont
déjà du mal à recruter c'est voilà c'est
tout le travail qui doit être fait dans
je pense dans le service public
d'habiter en France et Var d'arrêt de
volley de répondre de ses besoins des
familles qui voilà on estime à 160 000
le nombre de familles qui dont un des
membres non ça une formation ou un
emploi raison de défaut de mode de garde
et en même temps de faire ce travail
d'attractivité si on ne renforce pas
l'attractivité du métier on aura des de
l'éviction on aura des des
découragements des gens qui quittent la
profession et on n'arrivera pas à faire
à la fois à consolider l'existant la
qualité l'existant mais aussi à créer
les places et donc et à la fois à mieux
observer je l'ai dit il faut créer un
observatoire des métiers la qualité de
vie au travail pour avoir des données il
y a un sujet aussi de reconnaissance de
regard y compris de la société sur ces
professionnels
pour vous donner une anecdote souvent
quand on rencontrait les professionnels
il s'agacait de de du discours des
parents et moi m'ayant été père et je
pense que certains ici se reconnaîtront
en disant aux professionnels en quittant
le matin votre enfant amusez-vous bien
et c'est quelque chose qui les choque
parce que ça les renvoie voilà ça les ça
ni un peu leur prof leur compétences
professionnelles donc voilà et les
difficultés dans lequel ils sont donc
c'est extrêmement bon c'est encore une
fois je peux le dire de manière tout à
fait
décontractée puisque je l'ai dit un
certain nombre de fois mais en tout cas
c'est un message qui aujourd'hui ne
passe plus du tout compte tenu de la de
l'état de la profession donc c'est le
regard porté sur cette profession c'est
le aussi le contrôle qu'on peut avoir
sur les parcours professionnels parce
que comme on a un secteur en forte
tension de recrutement recrutement se
font vite et on peut avoir parfois
tendance à galvauder un peu les process
de recrutement donc c'est pour ça qu'on
propose aussi la mise en place d'une
carte professionnelle qui symboliquement
reconnaît un profession mais aussi
permet de manière cyclique de vérifier
les parcours et et les formations c'est
ma collègue l'a dit c'est les conditions
de travail et là le l'énorme
bâtimentaire doivent intégrer davantage
des conditions de travail et d'ailleurs
dans les instances de contrôle on parle
aussi on parle naknaf de la PMI mais il
y a aussi l'inspection du travail il y a
aussi la direction de la répression de
la consommation de la consommation de la
répression des fraudes qu'il faut aussi
davantage impliqués dans ces dans ces
processus de contrôle parce qu'on a vu
des situations effectivement de
conditions de travail qui serait qui ne
serait pas toléré dans d'autres lieux et
ça ça dit aussi mais les syndicats que
vous avez peut-être sans doute
auditionner le vous le diront c'est
extrêmement compliqué dans un secteur où
les où ce sont des petites unités de
travail le personnel est très volatile
de construire un dialogue social
extrêmement riche et nourri ce qui
explique aussi le défaut de données et
de et de d'observation très factuelle de
la situation et puis enfin je voudrais
en terminer par là il il y a deux sujets
il y a le celui de la
de
comment de la des conditions salariales
des conditions sociales de chacun de ces
de ses professionnels il y a une mission
qui est en cours auprès du Comité de
filière de la petite enfance pour
justement faire un état des lieux mettre
à des choses à plat entre ce régime
conventionnels les classifications les
rémunérations les conditions de travail
donc c'est à l'oeuvre et tous les et à
la fois les employeurs et à la fois les
les syndicats salariés sont mobilisés
sur ce sujet et ça doit produire cette
mission d'ailleurs je crois que
l'intitulé est justement sur
l'attractivité et puis enfin sur la
formation monsieur député c'est vrai que
relever le niveau de formation peut
créer des des difficultés puisque déjà
dans le recrutement c'est compliqué mais
encore une fois si on ne si on ne muscle
pas la formation si on aurait
ingénierait pas les diplômes nous
n'arriverons pas à rendre ce métier plus
attractif et donc on aura on n'arrivera
pas nous n'arrivons pas collectivement à
faire
amener ces deux sujets de front qui
peuvent paraître d'ailleurs ça a été
souligné difficilement compatible en
tout cas ça va demander beaucoup
d'énergie d'intelligence et sans doute
de moyens pour mener à la fois le front
qualitatif qui passe par la traiter des
métiers à la fois le front quantitatif
qui est quand même un besoin des
familles et notamment c'était un sujet
d'égalité professionnelle femme homme
extrêmement important
merci beaucoup j'espère que vous avez
encore un petit peu de temps à nous
accorder la salle est encore disponible
donc ce que j'ai encore deux questions
et demi
donc je vais laisser la parole à Madame
La Valette pour 2 minutes
madame la Présidente merci madame
monsieur les membres de l'aspection
générale des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues effectivement un parent ne
devrait jamais se demander si une crèche
est un lieu sur pour son enfant vous
disiez tout à l'heure on dit amusez-vous
bien on peut pas imaginer tout ce qu'on
a lu dans votre dans votre rapport une
grande majorité des maltraitances que
vous détaillez sont liées je pense un
peu comme dans les EHPAD à de la
maltraitance institutionnelle est quand
même à une logique assez malsaine de
rentabilité et je pense que ça c'est
aussi un peu le cœur quand même de ses
dérives c'est dérives elles sont
insoutenables et je pense qu'elles
découlent directement de cette vision
purement financière vous en parler les
couches non changées pendant une journée
des commandes de repas volontairement
réduites des enfants privés d'eau cette
logique comptable conduit aussi
naturellement à un manque de recrutement
il y a du personnel malmené vous en
parliez tout à l'heure docteur de ce
bien-être au travail qui n'existe plus
et donc évidemment par ricochet à des
enfants malmenés moi j'ai été
particulièrement choquée du bébé qui
vomit à force de pleurer parce que
personne ne s'en occupe des enfants
oubliés sur les toilettes des enfants
qu'on laisse pleurer pour qu'ils
s'endorment de fatigue ou encore des
enfants attachés aux radiateurs vous le
rappelez les crèches ne sont pas
épargnées par la domination de ces
grands groupes dont les intérêts
diffèrent radicalement en sans doute de
ceux des enfants et de leur famille
encore une fois un peu comme dans les
EHPAD selon un rapport de Matignon de
novembre 2021 les entreprises privées
détiendraient 20% des places disponibles
sur à peu près 80 000 places en crèche
pour un chiffre d'affaires compris entre
1,1 et 1,4 milliards d'euros
effectivement ça n'est pas rien on parle
de grosses ou en 2017 dans votre rapport
conjoint avec l'Inspection générale des
finances vous donnez l'exemple d'une
micro-crèche page dans laquelle 6 places
seraient réservés pour des entreprises
et quatre places tarifient directement
aux familles au maximum de la
tarification CMG et la marge dégagée par
la structure serait au total de l'ordre
de 74 832 euros ce qui est quand même
32% de son chiffre d'affaires cette
marge qui intéresse évidemment les
entreprises serait notamment permise à
l'existence d'un modèle économique qui
bénéficierait aux entreprises de crèches
en leur offrant un haut niveau de
rentabilité du fait d'une forte
mobilisation des financements publics
notamment du crédit d'impôt donc ma
question est la suivante depuis les
recommandations de 2017 et depuis ces
deux rapports est-ce que vous avez eu le
sentiment d'une volonté de la part des
pouvoirs publics de maître fin à la
marchandisation du secteur de la petite
enfance et simplement j'ai une réflexion
en vous écoutant parler à laquelle
j'avais pas pensé est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas mettre fin à ce collège unique et à
faire aussi des des filières
d'excellence pour s'occuper de nos
enfants je pense que on sort de là de
façon dont les bébés qui sont à naître
vont être pris en charge beaucoup merci
Monsieur Martinez
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
tiens à remercier les rapporteurs pour
la qualité de leur travail important à
plusieurs titres d'abord parce que vous
avez une parole officielle qui légitime
les alertes qui ont été émises par des
parents et des professionnels depuis de
nombreuses années et donc de voir dans
un rapport de Ligue 1 des mots qui sont
mis sur des situations dramatiques je
pense que c'est très important pour
notre prise de conscience collective et
des travaux qui sont importants aussi
parce que vous contentez pas de pointer
les situations mais vous mettez le doigt
sur les causes structurelles qui
provoquent cette maltraitance alors moi
dans le temps qui met un parti je
n'évoquerai qu'un seul sujet une seule
de ces causes structurelles qui est je
crois la question de la marchandisation
du secteur de la petite enfance j'ai il
y a quelques jours déposé une demande de
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
le modèle économique des entreprises de
crèche et leur dérive et d'ailleurs je
remercie les collègues présents ici qui
soutiennent ma démarche et bien écoutez
je dois dire que votre rapport à porter
de l'eau au moulin de ma demande de
commission d'enquête vous avez apporté
des éléments très précis alors
évidemment que je résumer ici mais j'en
prendrai un seul qui qui me paraît très
significatif vous nous dites entre 2012
et 2021 les dépenses en termes de masse
salariale des entreprises de crèche ont
été contractées de 2%. sachant que on
parle de professionnels dont beaucoup
sont payés au SMIC et sachant que sur la
même période le SMIC a augmenté de 13 %
juste pour qu'on prenne conscience de la
compréhension salariale qui a eu lieu
dans ces établissements privés lucratifs
et dans le même temps sur la même
période vous nous dites les dépenses
pour frais de siège augmenter de 51,8%
pour que là aussi tout le monde
comprenne c'est le siège qui paye les
dividendes aux actionnaires voilà on
voit cette situation et cette période de
2012 à 2021 que vous ciblez elle est
très intéressante parce qu'elle
correspond à un moment où les
entreprises de crèche ont vu leur
actionnariat se modifier on a eu à la
fois un mouvement de Fort concentration
et on a des fonds d'investissement qui
sont arrivés dans ce secteur je vais en
citer qu'un seul mais je le trouve très
représentatif l'entreprise de crèche
Babilou a un fond Antin infrastructures
Partners 2,6 milliards de capitalisation
boursière ils sont dans la fibre optique
ils sont dans les pipelines et ils sont
aussi dans les crèches en France donc je
pense que on a cette dérive qui qui a
lieu et ce qui permet de faire le bilan
quand même oui je vais très vite madame
la Présidente je vais très vite
de conclure justement sur le bilan qu'on
tire de l'ouverture au privé de ce
secteur parce que on voit que ça coûte
cher en argent public on voit que la
qualité d'accueil est pas au rendez-vous
et au moins le dernier argument qui est
resté c'était de nous dire ça permet
d'ouvrir des places donc déjà qu'il y a
une vision quantitative qui se qui se
critique mais ça permet d'ouvrir des
places alors qu'en réalité on sait bien
que le facteur limitant aujourd'hui
c'est son le nombre de professionnels et
pas le nombre de places qui sont verts
par les par les gestionnaires donc je
pense que même de ce point de vue là ce
n'est pas satisfaisant et je finis juste
avec ma question qui est qui est très
qui est très précise vous dites à
plusieurs moments dans votre rapport que
l'opacité des montages financiers SCI
holding etc empêche de voir ce qu'il a
réalité de l'utilisation de de l'argent
public donc de quel moyen
d'investigation supplémentaire vous
auriez besoin pour savoir quand la CAF
qu'on le collectivité mais un euro ou va
s'attacher merci merci
le point
[Musique]
c'est bon oui sauf erreur de ma part il
me semble que vous n'avez pas pu
répondre à ma question et comme nous
sommes des parlementaires il est
important que puissiez nous éclairer sur
les décisions de politique publique que
nous pouvons prendre qui sont peuvent
être votés qui peuvent être mises en
place de gouvernement qui peuvent être
année après année différent mais qui
peuvent avoir une incidence majeure je
pense que la déréglementation dans les
années 2010 de l'encadrement
pose le souci que nous voyons
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la seule
réponse mais ça en fait partie et comme
nous avons souvent des propositions qui
vont dans ce sens il est important que
vous puissiez nous éclairer et j'ai pas
entendu la réponse merci
beaucoup juste tout leurs événements si
on avait auditionné syndicats nous avons
déjà auditionné syndicats et mes chers
collègues je vous rappelle qu'on ne
disent la CNAF la semaine prochaine
puisque nous sommes dans un cycle
effectivement petit enfance et juste
dernière question de ma part tout à
l'heure vous parlez des problèmes de
financement un peu d'opacité de
financement etc est-ce qu'il faut
demander une mission à la Cour des
comptes je vous laisse répondre pour le
reste
sur la dernière question que vous avez
rappelé notre rapport est tout à fait
clair c'est-à-dire que une trajectoire
sur les normes le niveau de
qualification des professionnels depuis
10 ans a conduit à une diminution du
nombre de professionnels qualifs diplômé
de quel niveau de niveau 1 et donc à une
baisse tendanceielle de la qualification
moyenne des professionnels et nous
considérons que le niveau actuel de
qualification des professionnels n'est
pas suffisant
dans les crèches et que il faut viser un
relèvement de cette de cette trajectoire
sur le plan des questions financières
donc pour rappeler malgré tout que
on trouve des difficultés et des
difficultés à la fois sur les questions
de finance de juste financement juste
niveau et d'investissement de mise à
niveau des établissements etc dans tous
les domaines enfin dans tous les types
de crèches que ce soit des publics des
associatifs des privés lucratifs des
engagement financiers vis-à-vis de
certains établissements publics et
associatifs et réel aussi il faut aussi
le regarder mais s'agissant de des
établissements du secteur privé lucratif
vous avez rappelé un certain nombre
d'éléments que nous indiquons en analyse
cette analyse est une analyse des
risques puisque nous n'avons pas les
données pour faire ce stade et puis
c'était pas notre mission de l'analyse
financière précise y compris sur tel
groupe tel groupe donc effectivement
nous avons dessiné des zones de risque
notamment sur l'évolution de la masse
salariale sur l'évolution des frais de
siège sur l'évolution des dotations des
amortissements etc et donc
ce que nous avons préconisé c'est
notamment qu'il y ait des compétences de
contrôle d'une part qui soit donnée à
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales et à l'Inspection générale des
finances comme ça a été fait pour le
secteur des EHPAD enfin de façon
générale des établissements
médico-sociaux et qu'il y ait nous
parlions de transparence financière que
le financeur c'est-à-dire la CNAF la
transfamie et une capacité de
discussions et de négociation
précisément sur les frais de siège avec
la liste des prestations référentes
c'est pour ça que on parlait quand on a
évoqué la question des cépoms de ces
pommes de siège qui soit séparés de ces
bonnes d'établissement c'est-à-dire il
faut un moment que la branche famille
puisse négocier avec les sièges sociaux
des groupes sur ce que sont
effectivement c'est les visage à quel
niveau pourquoi ils sont imputés à tel
ou tel établissement selon telle clé de
répartition et quelles prestation ils
sont en train de financer avec ces frais
de siège et qu'on est ensuite de la de
la transmission de compte de façon
claire donc mes deux façons générale les
évolutions que nous préconisons ce sont
à peu près celles qui ont été décidées
dans le secteur EHPAD médico-social
après les après les les événements que
nous avons que nous avons connu
l'année dernière donc
les éléments de risque que vous évoquez
l'un et l'autre sur sur des recherches
excessives de rentabilité dans certains
établissements privés lucratifs c'est
pas tout ça mais dans certains
établissements on peut y avoir des
risques de dérive de ce type
les transformations des modalités de
financement que nous préconisons c'est
en partie pour répondre à ces risques là
puisque actuellement nous avons des
instruments de financement notamment la
page la Prestation d'Accueil du jeûne
enfant qui ne permet aucun regard sur la
façon dont l'argent est employé et par
ailleurs nous avons une grande partie du
financement qui faisait de dépenses
fiscale
qui par définition ne sont pas
pilotables et on a beaucoup de
difficultés à voir le niveau d'argent
public qui vient arrive dans une dans
une dans une structure dans une
structure donnée
donc
nous avons des recommandations de façon
générale
je ne suis pas convaincu qu'un rapport
de la Cour des comptes puisse aller
beaucoup plus loin que nous à ce stade
puisque précisément les compétences
n'existent pas enfin nous ne pouvons pas
aller contrôler les ni la Cour des
comptes ni nous les sièges sociaux de
groupe privé
de crèche de crèche
enfin s'agissant vous avez posé une
question sur le fait de
une remarque sur sur le fait de savoir
si la crèche était un lieu sûr et
évidemment il ne s'agit pas de
susciter
avant de panique ou chacun se dirait que
qu'il met son enfant dans un
environnement dans un environnement
absolument
chaotique c'est pas oui mais faut pas le
comprendre en ce terme que je crois
comme dans tout le nom mais comme dans
tout le parce que ma collègue disait
dans tous les établissements sociaux
médico-sociaux faisaient bon on est dans
des établissements où il y a de la
dépendance et la vulnérabilité donc il y
a des risques mais on a enfin
mais s'il y a des risques il y a des
faits parce que c'est parce que c'est le
coeur de cette de l'accueil de personnes
vulnérables et dépendante et en fait
faut savoir comment on les maintenant on
avance effectivement pour mieux les
maîtriser et mais il faut regarder aussi
en face les risques qui sont au cœur de
la relation d'accueil qui existe par
définition ensuite comment on les
maîtrise pour les parents sinon il
s'agisse c'est donc mon collègue
évoquait la reconnaissance des
professionnels par les parents c'est
voilà il faut il faut parler avec les
professionnels il faut prendre le temps
de s'intéresser à leur travail alors
métier voir comment ça se passe dans
l'établissement c'est bien bien sûr que
[Musique]
l'essentiel des des établissements et
des professionnels travail avec la
volonté de bien accompagner les enfants
mais là le constat c'est les conditions
sont pas suffisamment garanties pour que
quand ça devient compliqué on soit sûr
que on arrive à faire retomber les
choses
merci beaucoup effectivement grand
nombre de professionnels font leur
travail avec extrêmement de bonne
volonté avec toute la bien traitance qui
va bien mais on est effectivement dans
toutes les difficultés de ces
établissements médico-sociaux que soient
petit enfance ou EHPAD quand on commence
à avoir un dysfonctionnement c'est
compliqué de l'arrêter c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut qu'on agisse merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'être venu nous présenter
votre rapport merci pour votre travail
parce qu'il nous donne des pistes
d'amélioration ça c'est sûr je vous ai
donc rappelé la commission la
l'audition allégation de la CNAV la
semaine prochaine juste avant de nous
séparer sur
la future enfin le la mission
d'information
sur l'instruction des enfants en
situation de handicap compte tenu de des
tournes de groupe c'est Monsieur portier
et Madame Hugues qui
auront donc cette mission à nous rendre
dans les prochaines mois on va dire on
va vous laisser un peu de temps ce que
c'est un gros sujet merci beaucoup
je vous souhaite à tous et toutes une
bonne journée et merci encore de votre
venue